yes that's the unmistakable sound of
intergalactic war on the horizon a man
named Locke not to be mistaken with the
guy from lost the guy from Firefly and a
Jolly Green Giant who's being hunted
across the galaxy and jetpacks
that's right it's Halo 5 time and this
year's multiplayer offering is giving us
something new warzone pits 12 against 12
in PvP PvE TV anything that moves
basically players earn victory points
for every kill and the first to a
thousand wins or you can occupy the
three bases on the map and destroy the
enemy's core when it pops out of hiding
there's various paths to victory but if
you want to take a shortcut
then just watch this let's unravel that
req system first you need to earn req
points by either playing arena or
warzone or you can of course use
real-world fun bucks to buy them points
mean prizes use req points to buy req
backs that contain a mix of weapons
vehicles and items to use in-game you
get a free req pack by booting up
warzone for the first time or join a
Spartan Company on Halo Waypoint to get
another free pack and an add a bonus of
a gang of folks to play with next once
you've got some sweet sweet gear be
careful about when to use it cosmetic
items can be used all the time but
powerful weapons and vehicles can only
be used under certain circumstances you
have to spend energy to use req cards
and while energy does regenerate it
takes its sweet time also you have to
reach certain req levels every single
match before you can bust out the best
weapons and vehicles this is obviously
to balance the game so people don't just
spawn legendary items everywhere so ask
yourself what do you need now and what
might you need later when things get a
bit dicey you got to use your brain
before you use your Rex
down on the ground remember that every
little helps whether it's killing AI
other players or capturing faces
everything you do adds victory points to
that precious team pot getting you close
to that game-winning thousand points if
you're losing by a country mile though
focus your efforts on capturing those
bases and destroying the enemy's Power
Core admittedly that's pretty difficult
but I believe
even you but to really rack up those
points track down those legendary bosses
keep an eye out for drop ships and map
icons to find the biggest beasts on the
map these bosses are tough and you'll
need a couple friends to take him down
but getting that last hit Nets a couple
hundred points which is a mighty
contribution to the precious plot points
try waiting until the boss is down to at
least half health before you swoop in
and take the glory and if your entire
team is being kept busy trying to take
down the Baron there's no one defending
any faces your team may have captured so
always keep an eye on what your
teammates up to before you run off to
play hero the best defense is of course
a good offense but you got to remember
to defend - so there you have it a quick
start guide to the latest and biggest
halo game-mode ever any more tips or
tricks help your fellow Spartans out and
drop them in the comments box below
I'm Lucy you can catch me on Twitter at
Lucy James games and I'll see you next
time for some more in two minutes